many of you have written to me asking me
to talk about the situation
going on in the country colombia in
south america
and i want to start with that today the
new york times is a good piece
from yesterday updated this morning
summarizing what is going on there there
are now at least
19 people who have been killed in what
are being called pandemic related
protests but more specifically the
protests are because there's been a tax
overhaul connected to the pandemic which
has been proposed
that has turned into anger
from colombians about poverty about
inequality about economic conditions and
indeed as the new york times now
times now reports at least 19 people
have been killed
hundreds have been injured during days
of continued protests in colombia
tens of thousands of people have taken
to the streets to demonstrate
at at least proximally against a tax
overhaul
which uh is as the government claims
necessitated by
a financial whole created
by the pandemic and the president yvonne
duke announced he would withdraw the
current proposal
and put together a new plan saying that
this is a necessity for the country
monday the country's finance minister
announced that he would be resigning but
the protests continue and the repression
continues
and now it is becoming a larger protest
about
poverty in colombia about uh
unemployment in colombia
about inequality in colombia all of
which has been exacerbated by
the pandemic as we've seen in in many
countries
and i've talked a little bit about
what's going on in argentina my country
of birth
incredible anything you can imagine
related to the pandemic has happened in
argentina
officials with vaccines in the trunks of
their car
their cars continued
inflation out of control uh
overwhelmed medical systems strict
lockdowns on paper
that are actually not being followed in
particular by the countries i don't
really want to use the term elite but
upper middle class and many in the
professional class just living as if
there is no pandemic so
there's many examples brazil we have
talked about but this really sort of
taking on a unique shape and character
in colombia and the protests in part are
continuing
because even though the economic
proposal
has been pulled and will be replaced
with something else
the response from the state
has been extremely heavy-handed to put
it lightly and there have been instances
of police abuse captured on video
i'm not going to play them because we'll
just create problems for ourselves
one of one of the unfortunate realities
this is an aside but i think a relevant
one
one of the realities that we live with
in the united states
is that it has for decades
generally speaking not been a
part of protocol to show the violence
that takes place in war
when there is law enforcement repression
and so we in the united states have a
much more
sanitized view of what these
via what this violence looks like around
the world
and as a result of that the policy is
that
if we include a lot of the the violent
footage
it's not just about demonetization our
videos can actually get blocked all
together from from different platforms
and so
the video is out there if you want to go
look for it we won't be including it in
this
um broadcast but there are all sorts of
videos
of police brutality video where young
pro protesters
are seen shot by police
there is an instance of a 17 year old
marcelo agredo who is a ninth grader
sent out to march with his brother shot
by police
died uh after kicking a police officer
going by on a motorbike and uh now we
are seeing
um a sort of uh propaganda battle that's
also taking place
between those who say the police and the
military are now
in danger and they need to be able to
defend themselves a sort of tacit
defense really of the violence against
many of these protesters and of course
those saying
this is a harebrained idea
from the government in proposing this
economic reform
and then now that very same government
because there has been an outcry against
the proposal that they made are um
repressing protesters and um
all sorts of video that has been removed
from social media
already and all of the things that we
often associate with these circumstances
in latin america
are taking place now the there are
numbers that have started coming out i
mentioned already
uh tens of thousands of protesters and
certainly hundreds of injuries the
counter narrative is well 540 police
officers have also been hurt
and there have been endless instances of
property damage
and police say we've identified 17 000
people who have broken the public health
measures because they were protesting
without wearing masks so there is always
a counter narrative but the big picture
here is that
much like many other countries a
a financial shortfall the proposal that
was made economically would have
increased tariffs
on all sorts of everyday goods and
services which would make them
even less affordable for much of the
colombian people
and that caused an outcry and then now
the protesters are get
getting uh knocked knocked around so
we're going to continue following the
situation
all sorts of different uh colombian news
people
and musicians and actors that i follow
on social media have been actively
posting about this and
not enough people in the united states
even know that this is going on at this
point so that's the latest
and these numbers 19 dead there's a
reason why it's
at least 19 dead because in all
likelihood that number is going to go up
tragically so
and we will have more about this maybe
tomorrow maybe friday and
certainly by early next week one of our
sponsors today is
covid rescue fund covid rescue fund is
helping
small business owners who have lost
their businesses during covid
there are over 100 000 small businesses
that have had to close their doors
since the pandemic began there are many
organizations out there
helping businesses who are still open to
stay afloat
but covid rescue fund is one of the few
organizations working to help businesses
reopen who have had to close covet
rescue fund
crowdsources funds to provide grants up
to one hundred thousand dollars
for these owners to create new
businesses
i would implore anyone in my audience to
help covet rescue fund in their mission
by donating at covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the organization
the founders of covid rescue fund are
big fans of the david pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses as we can
the link is right underneath this video